hi I'm Nick Gillespie this is the reason
podcast please subscribe to us at iTunes
and rate and review us there as well
tell us what we're doing well and what
you think we should be doing more of and
maybe less of today we are talking with
Alex Epstein he is the president of the
Center for industrial progress and he's
the author of the great 2014 book the
moral case for fossil fuels and we're
going to be talking to him about Donald
Trump president-elect Trump's energy
policy what's good about it what seems
kind of cockeyed and what would be
better from an actual libertarian
perspective Alex thanks so much for
joining us great to be here so let's
start with talking about Trump's policy
you know as he is kind of one of one of
the big things that he talked about when
he was running for president against
Hillary Clinton in particular was he's
going to bring back the coal jobs he's
going to open up cold coal mines in a
way that Hillary had actually bragged
about shutting down coal mines but do we
have a do we have a clear sense of what
Donald Trump's energy policy is really
all about
he definitely has not said as much
specifically about energy as he has
about other fields certainly has also
been criticized for not sayings specific
enough things about other fields which
I'll let other people handle but what's
interesting is that what he has said
about energy
I believe policy-wise is the best of any
president since Reagan in terms of being
an advocate of Americans being free to
reach their full energy potential
particularly through the development of
energy from fossil fuels ie hydrocarbons
I think the coal claim in particular is
problematic in certain ways that I'm
happy to talk about but in general the
idea that we've got this enormous amount
of raw hydrocarbon material and we've
got this amazing developing technology
that includes hydraulic fracturing that
individuals and companies could use to
harm us and a benefit from it and it's
currently under control substantially by
an administration that vowed to end the
tyranny of oil in 2007 when Obama was
running yes oh well let's talk about
that because I mean all of this is said
against the backdrop really of almost
the past decade or so where the United
States has effectively become energy
independent right I mean it's a
long-sought goal and you know where we
would be a net exporter of you know
fossil fuels right or energy one way or
another and we basically accomplished
that despite the fact that the Obama
administration has been pretty proactive
against various kinds of drilling
operations both on land and offshore but
fracking and other types of technologies
have kind of proceeded a pace right yeah
there's a story that I can't verify but
that I've been told by a couple of CEOs
which is that around 2007-2008 they went
to talk to Obama and Steven Chu who is
the energy secretary at the time and
said to them look we have these in this
amazing suite of technologies around
shale energy around getting oil and gas
from this previously useless form of
rock and now we have these amazing
technologies and what they basically
said as well Steven Chu tells us we're
going to revolution a revolution in
batteries we've got all these promising
companies like Solyndra and we don't
need that plus we want we want the age
of oil to end in our time which is that
Obama said in a speech and Detroit where
he also analogized the oil industry to
communists and fascists he said just as
you know the age of oil just as we ended
communism fascism so we need to end the
age of oil so my view on the whole shale
revolution which i think has been the
most economically positive revolution of
our time is that we were lucky that the
politicians didn't know about it so our
energy prosperity has recently depended
upon the ignorance of politicians would
have otherwise stopped it and that it's
a very bad state to be in in terms of
your potential talked a little bit about
the the shale
the UNAM revolution because that that's
what we're talking about are things that
are happening up in around Williston
North Dakota slant drilling in Texas
fracking moving into I guess what we
would call the industrial Midwest or the
Northeast places like Ohio Phil
Pennsylvania upstate New York what what
are the contours of this you know of the
way that the shale revolution has
reshaped our energy supply and demand
just so people get a sense of what we're
talking about when we talk about shale
we have this general idea of oil and
there's oil in the ground and we think
of it as this uniform thing and this
fixed thing but really what there are
are different oils different forms of
hydrogen and carbon that can potentially
be in liquid form that exist in ways
that are naturally much easier to get or
much harder to get so that first we had
oil at sixty nine point five feet in
Titusville Pennsylvania there was a lot
of natural pressure it was an amazing
accomplishment at the time but now it
would be super easy to get but that was
just a tiny tiny tiny percentage of the
potential oil resource in the ground and
what we've done over time is we've taken
unusable potential resources and we've
turned them into usable and for decades
and decades and decades this type of
rock called shale which broadly speaking
is often the source for other forms of
oil from looser more migrating forms of
oil that's been this dream because if
you could get to that there's tons of
hydrocarbon resource in it but how do
you get it because it's so tightly
packed and to give one historical
example one of the heroes and Iran's
Atlas Shrugged which came out of 1957 is
a character named Ellis Wyatt and his
signature accomplishment is to get oil
from shale and this is this is what the
industry has actually been doing through
a series of innovations that most
prominently involve breaking open the
rock in a certain way using water
instead of say melting the rock which
would be what much less energy if it
by doing that but also by being able to
exactly know where to put the powerful
streams of waters all this amazing
modern technology but the way I think of
it as somebody figured out how to take a
rock that's 6,000 feet underground and
use it to charge your iPhone that's
what's happening now in I'm looking at
data from your your 2014 book the moral
case for fossil fuels between 1980 and
2012 you note that in in the United
States alone that oil consumption went
up by about eight point seven percent
natural gas up by twenty eight point
three percent coal up by 13 percent
twelve point six percent what kind of
effect did that have I mean one of the
reasons why I'm you know I expect why
Obama and Steven Chu were talking about
we want to end well is because oil is
dirty oil as a as a form of fuel or when
it gets transformed into electricity it
causes a lot of pollution what was going
on in America at the same time that our
you know oil gas and coal consumption
was was ratcheting up pretty quickly in
terms of pollution with energy with any
technology we always need to look at the
benefits we get from it including the
unique benefits that we might not be
able to get from other technologies and
also different risks and side effects
and when you hear terms like dirty
versus clean it's often a very
superficial characterization in that
they're not looking at say the process
of getting the materials for wind
turbines or solar panels the process of
disposing of them it's just a giveaway
that somebody has a superficial view
because what you're always dealing with
is degrees of these things you're
dealing with degrees of cleanliness
really degrees of safety that's the key
issue so that's one aspect but then the
other aspect you indicated is there's
this whole issue not just of how much
side effect or how much by-product or
how much risk is there but
what's the benefit and in this case the
benefit of energy and energy being more
affordable and more reliable is that
every individual directly or indirectly
is empowered because energy in the
energy industry is the industry that
powers every other industry energy is
really our ability to use machines to
improve our lives and the reason we're
prosperous is because we live in a
machine based civilization rather than a
manual labor based civilization so the
more plentiful the more affordable the
more reliable energy is the more we can
do in every aspect of life and a lot of
what the moral case for fossil fuels
documents is that with things you might
not expect such as clean water or the
advance of knowledge or protection from
climate having affordable energy helps
all of those well let's let's talk about
the the moral case for fossil fuels
about you you write in the book early on
that first off you know the moral case
you making the moral case you say that I
hold human life as the standard of value
talk a little bit about that and how
because the book in many ways is even as
it's a moral case it makes a lot of kind
of cost-benefit analyses what do you
mean when you say that the the that
human life is the standard of value that
you're kind of using to judge how
effective or how moral or immoral or you
know kind of beneficial a particular
technology is we often use moral
terminology like good and bad when
discussing things and whenever you use
that terminology whether we admit it or
not there's a question of by what
standard are you saying that it's good
or about how do you measure good or bad
and this is this is the terminology that
I use which I'm Randall sees is called
standard of values that's by what
standard are you measuring good and bad
and what's interesting about the issue
of energy and also many other issues
that strongly involve our relationship
to our environment
is that the working standard that is in
use is not actually what maximizes what
I call human flourishing we might think
that we really care about that but if we
look at our methodology in action if we
look at what we're prioritizing our
standard is actually often to minimize
human impact so maximizing human
flourishing versus minimizing human
impact and those are very very different
things and I like to run through
examples when I speak to audiences like
okay well minimizing human impact you
might think that sounds good as a way of
thinking about morality and our
environment and this is kind of the
boyscout ideal of when you take a take
away or break camp that you leave the
place exactly as you found it or a
little bit better off right that you
that you traipse through the world
through the natural world with a light
touch right but that that policy in that
context is somehow a universal and what
I ask people is well if we had that
policy would we have ever turned a patch
of dirt and trees into New York City
well obviously not we weren't leaving it
as we found it we were changing it
dramatically or would you ever have a
kid well know that that is about the
biggest impact you could imagine or and
then I'll ask well if it's supposedly
about environment which is a better
country if you want to minimize impact
North Korea or South Korea and they'll
say well North Korea and which is pretty
jarring and then I'll say well which
country is a better environment and
they'll say well obviously South Korea
so slightly very wrong with this as an
ideal yet we use it as an ideal we use
it as a metric and the problem is that
it's it's it's treating impact as the
key issue whereas impact is an aspect of
what benefits human flourishing so we
want to maximize our positive impacts on
nature for human beings and we want to
minimize our negative impacts to human
beings and if we think of it that way
then whether we're thinking of co2
emissions or particulate matter or
energy poverty we're going to look at
all the considerations in the context of
humans and I think this issue actually
is the key to a lot of debates such as
what they call the climate change debate
these are actually it's actually
were not clear on our standard rather
than there's really a debate over or say
climate models well well let's talk
about that a little bit because
obviously you know and climate change is
a huge issue and I was just watching a
documentary on TV that was about UFO a
guy who investigates people who believe
in UFOs and he was saying he's a skeptic
and you know he mentioned in the same
breath as UFO you know nuts people who
believe in UFOs that well there's also
climate deniers which is a phrase that
gets used a lot as if people are denying
the idea that there's such a thing as
climate but but when it comes to climate
change and when it comes to
anthropocentric impact on the on the
Earth's climate you're not saying that
burning fossil fuel doesn't have impact
doesn't have effects both good and bad
but what you're saying is is that we're
looking at it or we're kind of
evaluating it on a cockeyed spectrum or
we're saying the big if if you're all
you're talking about is how much co2 are
we releasing into the atmosphere we're
trying to measure co2 that that's just
missing the big story which is really
how it affects human lives and and and
allows for or retards human flourishing
yes so imagine that you have two parents
who are trying to decide whether and how
to vaccinate their children and so
they're looking for information on this
and they find something very strange
which is that they never can find a full
context assessment of what are the
benefits and risks of vaccines compared
to the alternatives instead all they can
find is discussion of vaccine side
effects and so you have an Internet
intergovernmental panel of vaccine
side-effects and that's all people talk
about is vaccine side effects and
they're inclined to vaccinate their kids
in a certain way and then they start
being called vaccine side effect deniers
because they say well you're going to
use vaccines but don't you know they
have side effects and aren't your
vaccine side effect denier you think
well that's like really wrong about that
and the thing that's that's wrong
is that you can't just look at the
potential negatives of something if your
concern
is to benefit your kid or to benefit
human beings in general you have to look
at the full context which means both
positives and negatives you have to have
a clear standard which in this case is
the well-being of your kid or you know
the well-being of human beings more
broadly you have and you have to look at
them with precision if you say vaccine
side effects do you mean full-blown
autism or do you mean a rash and what
you see with the climate issue is people
don't look at it as an aspect of fossil
fuels as a potential side effect of
fossil fuels the effect of co2
they don't look it that way this is
ignore the positives and then they are
not at all clear about whether it's the
equivalent of autism which would be an
Al Gore type you know 30 foot rise in
sea level so for Florida Florida
disappearing London England disappearing
all that kind of stuff right they're not
clearing whether it's that or whether
it's a two feet over 80 years or 90
years which is store historically you
know very uninteresting and sea level
rises dramatically slowed you just look
at week Wikipedia over the past twenty
thousand years and and the enterprise of
the moral case is to say okay let's
let's use a rational thinking method
let's have a clear metric of how we're
going to choose what's good and bad and
then let's look at carefully at the full
context of positives and negatives and
once you do that you just see that the
alleged negatives are either very
overblown or sometimes they're the
reverse and then climb but it's it's the
reverse because the effective co2 is
very uninteresting but the effect of
having a lot more energy of a lot more
people having a lot more energy allows
us to deal with climate which is
naturally very dangerous it's not our
friend allows us to build a durable
civilization and run a durable
civilization so every number we have
about how safe we are from climate is
its it we're safer and safer every year
and well first off so the the
catastrophic kind of scenarios that are
in certain climate models you think
those are extremely unlikely to happen
that's that's one of the bets that
you're
making right I wouldn't call it a bet
because I believe that the burden of
proof is on someone who asserts
something so if you are making a claim
about the futures just like well a
psychic says something I know so I'm
betting against the psychic and then
that might seem like a crazy comparison
but you know most most models that
people have in predicting the future are
very wrong I mean they simply don't work
they're taking on very different
difficult problems even if the problems
are solvable and often they're taking on
unsolvable problems given current
knowledge and often it's the most
irresponsible people and often inept
people who claim to have solutions these
unsolvable problems so one of my
colleagues Erik Dennis who's a physicist
also has a lot of experience building
mathematical models
he once analogized it to well you could
be the best person at building a model
or a plan of how to get how to make a
spaceship to go to Alpha Centauri but
you still don't really know how to do it
and so the person who claims that you
don't say well he's the world authority
on getting to Alpha Centauri you say
well this guy is kind of a crank and the
question with these models is on what
basis are they doing this and would I
note in the book is that the basic
mechanism that we know about the
relationship between co2 and the warmth
and atmosphere is diminishing or
logarithmic effect which means that
every new molecule of co2 adds less
warmth than the last and that the claims
that there's some that thus increasing
co2 levels portends doom those that has
a lot of speculation in it that has not
been validated by the models that are
based on on that thinking and in fact
those models have been invalidated and
and that's because a lot of the models
or most of the models that get taken
seriously by important thinkers and
whatnot really are over predicted or
over predict where we should be by now
and I know in a in a kind of more banal
way you you have you quote predictions
by people like Paul Ehrlich and people
like Bill I'm sorry I make it yeah Bill
McKibben and others who you know by this
time or even ten years ago
fifteen years ago whole parts of the
whole parts of the world wouldn't exist
anymore because of types of climate
change that never obviously never
happened yeah the first chapter of the
book is called the secret history of
fossil fuels and it deals with the issue
of track record if you ever have people
making dramatic predictions you have to
be on the premise that this is something
very hard to do and one thing that's
great is if you can know the track
record of these particular individuals
which includes their method of thinking
and then any prediction models that they
have used and in this case there's great
news in this respect in that the same
people who are thought leaders today or
many of the same people have been making
predictions based on the same basic
model of how the world works and they've
been doing it for 35 or so years so we
have a lot of evidence as to the
reliability of these people and the
quality of their thinking methods and
what we find is that they have not just
been wrong when they've predicted things
in the 70s that are you know that mirror
so exactly what they say today so if
anyone goes to moral case for false
appeals calm you can get that chapter
for free you'll see it's just it's just
uncanny and then it's not just that they
were wrong it's that they were reverse
right that as they said something would
happen really badly like we would run
out of X resource and now we have more
of the resource than ever they said you
know john holdren obama's top science
adviser said well there's you know
there's going to be a billion people who
die from climate related famine by 2020
and yet the use of fossil fuels plus the
non climate catastrophe have made it
possible for billions of new people to
be fed so it's reverse right as the best
term I have because we don't really have
a term for how wrong they have been so
that track record is very important in
assessing things and and not only is
that not raised by them it's not raised
by the media and in fact the media will
sometimes say I don't know where this
comes from they'll even say well this
person has a really good track record so
they've said this if James Hansen is one
of the
catastrophists and they say he's had a
shockingly good track record they don't
give any evidence because none exists
but it's it's you know if you just look
at your own just do a little google
search on quotes from somebody for the
last several decades and you should do
it for me too like for instance with the
peak oil scare look at what people were
saying about peak oil in 2008-2009
because you look at say Michael Lynch
whom I think is the best thinker in that
field you'll see him saying exactly what
happened and being ridiculed for it as a
lesser thinker in that aspect of energy
you'll see me saying that it's
ridiculous and explaining why and and
peak oil was the idea that we had
reached a maximum production and that it
was going to be declining you know that
we had finally started to you know we
were really having a suck hard on the
straw to get oil out of out of the
ground and of course that didn't happen
there was essentially a cycle where
prices went up so people started
predicting because it fit in with their
theory of the end of the world and
moving past fossil fuels that okay this
was the beginning of the post oil period
talk a little bit about the value of
cheaper energy and and if you can put it
on you would mention that you know and
the book is certainly filled with
excellent examples of this but of how
when energy consumption goes up wealth
goes up but and then put that in the
context of how being wealthy or how does
that make a country more resilient or a
population more resilient against
weather and against kind of climate
problems extreme weather you know I mean
it took a little bit about that because
one of the things that is amazing is how
much more energy you know the world is
using again quoting from your book
between 1980 to 2012 overall the world
increased its oil consumption by about
40 percent coal by over a hundred
percent gas by a hundred natural gas by
a hundred and thirty one percent what
are the benefits
more cheaper fossil fuel use as I
mentioned it's it's really Universal you
can't find an area where it doesn't
affect it because the ability to have a
machine do our physical work versus us
having to do our physical work is is
just life and death and with what when
we have energy what we have then is the
potential to have these amazing machines
that turn man into Superman you think of
that in a very literal way it's really
remarkable what we can do and super II
know Superman's power is power and
Superman is able to do that I mean his
fictional character but B stores tons
and tons of energy within himself and
you mentioned the realm of climate and I
find this fascinating because it's so
common sense once you realize that but
we don't realize it and by we I include
myself and one way to think of it is
this there's a statistic called climate
related deaths which quantifies how many
people die every year from the things
that are supposedly getting worse storms
floods droughts extreme heat extreme
cold wildfires and you'd think that if
we were assessing what is the state of
climate in terms of how is it affecting
affecting human flourishing we would
look at that number and that number
would be discussed but there's almost
nobody who discusses that number
the person who popularized it a little
bit as Inder Golani of the Cato
Institute and he's the person who
familiarized me with it and then I think
I've spread it quite a bit myself but
it's kind of crazy that were supposedly
concerned about climate and yet we don't
actually quantify the effect on human
beings which goes I believe to the idea
that we're not really concerned about
human beings we just think it's wrong
for us to change things so if we hear
that we're putting more co2 in the
atmosphere we just think we violated the
commandment let's not change things
versus we can show that it's a problem
but what we see is that hey wait a
second Nature doesn't give us a safe
climate that we make dangerous it gives
us a really dangerous climate that we
need to make safe and you just think of
it in a common-sense way look at all of
these ways in which we've taken the
really dangerous climate and made it
safe I'm sitting in San Francisco right
now I have engaged in massive climate
change by renting an apartment that
changes the nature of my atmosphere
every single second I am in this
apartment it is my climate is
dramatically different to a far greater
degree than any alleged outside change
that's going on so the effective
atmosphere we live in is completely
artificially modified and then I'm
protected from the elements by having
sturdy housing and I'm protected from
extreme heat and extreme cold by heating
and air-conditioning and you can go on
and on and on and it's just remarkable
and with this manifests itself in is
that in the 1930s even which is somewhat
industrialized time but around the world
you have the modern equivalent of and
many years 10 million climb related
deaths a year and now will typically
have 30,000 climb related deaths so
climate is actually a climate danger
which is a much more precise term than
climate change is is not a problem
that's been created by fossil fuels it's
a problem that's been solved by
technology including fossil fuels well
and talk about you know I I was checking
out some other numbers and in 2016
essentially the United States will which
has produced many many more things and
as I noted before energy consumption is
way up from where was twenty thirty
years ago we will admit the same amount
of carbon as we did in 1992 and that's
mostly due to fracking and kind of shale
the shale revolution that you've talked
about so and there isn't a city in
America where the air quality and the
water quality is not better than it was
in 1980 essentially I mean you know
there are some specific examples I guess
with water like Flint Michigan which has
everything to do with political
stupidity and nothing to do with
technology or irreversible natural order
is it the case though I mean can the
world as a whole keep burning
more fuel and still like everywhere in
the world like air pollution will become
less you know it talked a little bit
about what is the technology what is the
innovation that allows for that the
answer is definitely I do separate co2
from other what we can call pollutants
even that's misleading because the issue
with everything is there's a certain
threshold at which something starts to
become dangerous and then there is a
certain threshold you know at that
threshold it because it can become an
oculus or even it can become better like
you can be better off you know the
studies of kids where certain amounts of
dirt are good for them and then if they
are exposed to too many germs and that
can be a big issue and the issue of
threshold is just extremely
misunderstood and the dominant theory is
called the linear no-threshold view
which is the premise that well if
something is harmful in some quantity
it must be harmful in any quantity and
so what you have is very very small
amounts of emissions thanks to
technology today this is not like the
London Fog in the 1940s which is a real
problem very or even modern China which
isn't nearly as bad as London Fog what's
still really an issue we have in the
United States some of the cleanest air
in the world and you have all these
bogus studies or almost all bogus
studies claiming that that this is a
huge source of death versus you know the
real sources of death being poverty
related or behavior related and the
reason that we can have this incredibly
clean air including around many modern
coal plants is that is that what
technology enables us to do is enables
us to take the raw energy in the coal
and extract it in such a way that it
doesn't have nearly as much by-product
that's put in a place that's harmful to
human beings so the way we think about
energy is very wrong because we think
about it as just a material that we use
as energy but really every form of
energy is a process that begins with a
set of raw materials and then the key is
how do you combine those in such a way
that we can get it cheaply plentifully
reliably and healthily or safely and
theoretically you can get caught you get
the energy from the coal and 100% clean
way and you could get energy in the form
of wind turbines in a way that killed
tens of thousands of people in making it
or even and deploying it in in various
ways so what we see with that any
technology you can make safer and
cleaner over time and with this one
what's great is it's very efficient
terms of its resource usage in terms of
producing cheap plentiful reliable
energy as compared to what I call the
unreliable solar and wind which are
dealing with these unreliable inputs and
that just creates a huge mess everywhere
they're deployed so you have this thing
and we're getting good at dealing with
the byproduct and I wish that if we
lived in a more Pro human flourishing
world what would happen is people would
be even more obsessed with improving the
way that we burn these things the way we
extract that energy they'd be excited
about that versus the unreliable is
going down by a few cents and yet we're
still forced I'm still forced to pay for
my neighbor solar panels and every
single country that uses these things in
a large scale basically doubles its
energy price can you talk a little bit
you know in a quick way about why how
are so solar panels for instance how are
they a bad alternative to existing
fossil fuel technology or are they
something that over time will become
more reliable and less harmful you know
what what is your case against solar
panels that one thing that is implicit
in discussions among free marketers
which both of us are is that this the
kinds of decisions were talking about
should be made by free individuals and
this should be that the basis of energy
policy that you should have freedom of
competition among energy producers and
freedom of choice among energy consumers
and that you have and the basic way to
do this is by protecting property rights
because you protect the right of
individuals and companies to use land to
develop energy on and you also
they're right to be on their land
without contamination by others they
look the broadly schematic context in
which these energy decisions are made
and the reason to talk about the virtues
of fossil fuels and the alleged vices of
fossil fuels is because we've been so
misled about this where we're taught to
think that to use fossil fuels is to
violate people's rights in a wholesale
way and thus there's this case that well
we need to do something dramatic about
co2 or we really shouldn't be able to
use it at all because in the aggregate
it's violating everyone's rights and
what the moral case for fossil fuels is
doing is really looking well is this
really such a technology that's just so
toxic that it's violating everyone's
rights oh we should and then you see no
absolutely not
it'sit's unbelievably moral to be used
and thus there's certainly not a
political justification for putting in
this category of
of some menace to society so it's to say
that there's a moral case for fossil
fuels is not to say that other things
are bad but in understanding the
particular morality of fossil fuels it
is valuable to look at the potential
alternatives particularly if you have
concerns about the the emissions and
then looking at the potential
alternatives you see this very curious
thing that the most promising
alternatives that are not co2 emitting
nuclear power and hydroelectric power
are opposed by the people who claim to
care about co2 and they're generally
supported by supporters of fossil fuels
I'm certainly a big supporter and then
yet these two technologies solar and
wind which I call the unreliable because
they deal with these intermittent inputs
which means that you can't count on them
and you can't count on them in very very
dramatic ways which means they have to
be essentially a hundred percent
replicated by the actual network which
makes them essentially deadweight and
unnecessary wherever they're deployed
and that that adds cost ever good so you
can see this is the fundamental problem
and there's a lot that you would have to
do to deal with that including some
magical storage thing and then I'd talk
about this in Chapter two
of the book but it's just a mess but
what I want to point out is it why are
we why are we so obsessed with the Sun
and the wind as sources and it goes back
to this idea of minimizing impact its
allegedly minimally impactful its
allegedly natural to use the Sun and the
wind and it's bad to dam a river because
that's changing nature it's bad to
create man-made radiation to generate
energy because that's that's changing
nature it's bad to use energy that adds
more co2 to the atmosphere because
that's changing nature an allegedly
solar wind aren't and of course
everything we do change is nature so if
solar and when ever became practical the
green movement would oppose them so the
reason that they support them is because
there's only one form of energy that the
green movement has ever supported and
that is imaginary energy and it's
interesting when you start talking about
it in that way I was thinking of Samuel
Coleridge has a poem about the Aeolian
harp as the ultimate instrument because
it's a it's a mechanism that the wind
blows through it and makes beautiful
music and so it's totally somehow
natural even though it's obviously an
artificial contract a constructive human
activity and there's a lot of
romanticism in a very negative and kind
of naive way and environmentalism that
you know what we want is an imagined
world that has very little to do with
the world that we necessarily live in
talk for a second about you know in
terms of technological innovation what
is the role and this is more of a kind
of libertarian nerd market nerd question
what is the role of the government
saying you know you were talking about
property rights and whatnot into the air
is not necessarily a commons but it's
it's very hard to figure out who's
polluting and then how do you you know
how would you bring them to court in
some kind of common-law situation what
is the role positive or negative
of certain types of government mandates
whether it's a catalytic converter or
certain types of scrubbers on
smokestacks to clean up air you know
what I mean
wood coal companies
on their own wood gas fracking companies
on their own wood energy companies on
their own say okay you know what we're
going to do is we're going to keep
making the technology cleaner smarter
cheaper better is you know have have
government edicts and mandates had
beneficial effects on on our the air
that we breathe the water that we drink
advocates of government intervention
always take credit for anything positive
that happens in the realm that they have
taken over which I find just very weird
so let's say you know you take the case
of government-run universities and
there's some good graduate from that and
they say well look look it was great
that we did this because there was this
great graduate but what about what about
what it would have happened had people
been free where would that individual
have gone what kind of schools would
exist etc it's our so the issue there's
an issue of well how does the government
protect in this case us against
contamination of air by different
industrial processes and the government
has taken action in that realm and that
action has helped people in that because
it's it's done something in that realm
it's there's been some good in that that
is some of the actions it's taken have
cleaned up some people there the
question is does it have remotely the
right approach and is is that the
approach to use going forward and I
favor the property rights based approach
they're there many libertarians that
disagree with me on this and there's
interesting back and forth between me
and Bryan Caplan of George Mason is a
good friend and wrote a very positive
review of the book but he raised some
interesting criticisms we went back and
forth on like if co2 was an issue would
a co2 tax be good and in general I think
that the first thing with any of these
issues is to identify what is the actual
threshold of danger like to be really
clear on on what constitutes an actually
harmful level because people tend to
assume this idea that well any amount of
it is bad any of
if it is text and should be taxed or
whatever and I want to know okay with
air to the extent of our knowledge
what's actually a risk that goes above
the normal level of background risk that
we deal with all the time
so that's one question that has to be
incorporated another question has to be
is how necessary is this risk given
current technology so let's say you took
London in the 1800s
using coal if you had held them to our
air quality standards you just say okay
don't use coal and they would have to a
man objected to that because they would
have said well no we have a right to act
to benefit our lives and this technology
is essential to our lives and it's
inevitable that we have a certain amount
of by-product given technology whereas
as the technology evolves then we you
know then we can live we can have the
energy and we can have less pollution so
there's a contextual element we always
have to look at what's the what's the
positive involved in the process not
just what's the potential negative and
with the negative you have to be clear
on the threshold and there I think there
can be a role with these aggregate cases
words one individual doesn't do anything
by burning coal but in the aggregate we
can create a problem I think there's a
role of the government you know figuring
out hey is there a way is there a way
for this to be reduced but I think it
does it on the basis of pseudoscience I
tend to I tend to be in favor of of
actually the way that people think of
cap-and-trade in the sense that if you
have an idea with co2 and it's false
because co2 is not dangerous in this way
but if you have the idea that there's a
certain amount of co2 that the
atmosphere can handle that you know that
that's safe and then there's a point of
danger well then in effect there needs
to be a legal structure such that we
don't go above that to pass a tax is a
very odd way of doing it it's kind of
messy and you might you I think of it
more like radio spectrum like we've
created value through there's a certain
amount of co2 bandwidth that we can use
and we've created the first people to
create value actually have the right to
that and then the next people need to
find other ways of doing it or the first
people can sell their rights but in any
case you need to have the
oh the same thing is true I think I ran
one suggested not sure but you know with
LA and smog she said look it doesn't
bother me
I I'm dubious of laws about it but you
could say look there's only a fixed
number of with today's technology we're
only going to allow a fixed number of
cars in LA and the people who created
that value are the ones who get to do it
and that would have spurred innovation
so that those that's like schematically
what I think is a scientific Pro human
way of thinking about these things
versus just let's reduce emissions in
the in a vacuum right
you had mentioned ein Rand several times
the magazine and website and video
platform I work for is called reason
partly in homage to her the founder of
the magazine in 1968 Lani Friedlander
was kind of an Objectivist we are
heretic heretics too many Randy uns but
talk a little bit about mine Rand and
her role in your in your project at the
Center for industrial progress
how does she motivate you and inspire
you when I was 18 years old I started
reading a couple of things on the issue
of environment which just completely
blew my mind and I indicated the issue
earlier but I'll put it in a slightly
different way as the issue that well
environmentalism so to speak in its
essence says that we should minimize our
impact on nature yet man by his nature
survives by impacting nature that's what
we do we use the productivities is using
reason to transform nature to meet our
needs so there's a movement that says
the essence of human survival is bad and
that is that is wrong and I was in a set
of classes at a time which had a lot of
environmentalists
both on the teacher level and the
student level and I was just this was
such a clear idea in my mind that this
is the totally wrong way of thinking and
that this is wrong
and the people whom I had learned from
were you can call them Randy ins or
Objectivists either way but these are
these were scholars in the tradition of
eine rands thought and I had heard of
her in high school but I really read her
seriously in college actually starting
with her letters to various figures that
was kind of random I saw it in the Duke
library but ultimately I read Atlas
Shrugged which for me as for many people
was was just a revelation and in
relevant to this issue in two ways one
is just that the way she thought really
fascinated me in that she just would she
would look at the world and she'd really
look for commonalities among ideas and
put them in very precise ways that I
never heard so she identified for
example that a lot of our thinking about
morality involved the idea that one
person's need is a claim on another
person's life and however you want to
analyze that that just blew my mind wait
I never thought about that
yet I've heard all these you know
thousands of instances of discussing it
yet nobody ever United it that way in
the same way that these scholars and I
learned later she had identified oh when
we talk about environment we have this
premise that we should be minimizing
impact and she could just you could
think in this incredibly clear way and
then that that inspired me because I've
been obsessed with logic since I was a
kid and then at the same time I also
loved business and but I wasn't really
into industry and she had this book
where the industrialists were heroes the
Transformers of nature were heroes and
that really helped me a lot in my
thinking and then 9 10 years later when
I became interested in energy and
actually afraid of issues like the co2
issue so I was not at all
I didn't I didn't have this prejudgment
that it was impossible that co2 be a
problem is actually concerned but I did
have this context that industry is
crucial to human life that logical
thinking is necessary and that the green
movement is not focused on maximizing
human benefit it's focused on minimizing
human impact and that's the opposite of
maximizing human benefit and then when I
studied I saw Oh
a reason they're obsessed with co2 is
not because it's at a level that's
really going to hurt us it's because
they think it's wrong we have no right
to change the amount of co2 in the
atmosphere and so that means when you
said as I quoted earlier I hold a human
life as the standard of value you would
if there was evidence produced that
massive industrial civilization was
destroying human life or really you know
impacting it horribly negatively killing
people more people than it helped I mean
that would you would flip your your
positions right well I already do that
all the time and the sense that
industrial civilization isn't a single
thing
it's the aggregate of many people's
actions in many companies actions and
producers in their decisions and
consumers and their decisions do harmful
things all the time so if you take say
the food industry I think a lot of what
the food industry produces and what
people choose to consume are very
harmful but I don't I don't react to
that by saying oh industry is bad
mechanized agriculture is bad nor do I
think of it in this bizarre way like
let's be as natural as possible that's
incoherent but I try to think well let's
what promotes human flourishing and we
need political policies of freedom to
give us the chance to produce the best
food and to consume the best food but it
doesn't guarantee it and so if I see you
know privately or publicly hey like
there are these trends that we have that
are damaging to life also yeah the
industry is doing a bad thing so yeah
and if so thus any any change in
behavior or change in knowledge about
the significance of say a form of
omission that should lead us to change
our conclusion and I think ultimately
what I do in my book and and the real
project that I'm undertaking is to is to
guide people and how to use technology
for its proper purpose of promoting
human flourishing that's really the
mission of my work going forward and
that that means that it's not just all
technology as good all industry is good
all uses are good or not technophiles or
industry files we're lovers of humans
who recognize that used properly these
things have amazing potential and used
improperly they can do a lot of beds so
let's think carefully about how to use
them properly and you really take the
industry and again the industry but the
energy industry many of the leading
players and certainly major oil and gas
companies to task because you say that
you know they seem to have bought into
the argument and you talk about
companies like BP and Mobil and whatnot
on their websites where they don't even
mention what they do or what they
produce on their webpage is often
because they essentially by the
environmentalist argument that they're
doing something immoral they're doing
something wrong
have you had much of an impact or the
Center for industrial progress what kind
of impact have you had to get the
industries that would most benefit from
your framework for understanding what
they're doing I mean are they getting on
board with you or are they more and more
kind of like oh we're not British
Petroleum anymore we're BP we really
don't have anything to do with oil or
gas or anything like that the American
companies I think have been
substantially affected by my work and
that's that's very satisfying to me for
many reasons including just from a
broader perspective in the history of
capitalism it's been very rare that
businesses take any kind of proper moral
stand
certainly one involving free markets and
you know I had this working theory when
I started the Center for industrial
progress but I didn't know if it was
true that if I could if I could give
arguments for what an industry does well
in a way that was appealing to the
public and that was more appealing than
their appeasing self-evidently cowardly
propaganda like the beyond petroleum
thing if I could if I could give them
that that would be a financial asset to
them and I could sell it to them as
messaging both
their employees would be much more
motivated by a message that what they do
is empowering the world and what they do
is not as bad as it used to be it which
is kind of the most inspiring message
these tab but also inspiring the public
about the potential the opportunities
that we have by using these amazing
technologies and so the past several
years one of the things I've done behind
the scenes that I think is the type of
thing I'm supposed to be ashamed about
or height which I never do very proud of
it is is talk a lot to companies as a
guest speaker as an advisor about how to
think about what they do so the
framework the human flourishing
framework that I use and then show them
how that's the basis of persuading other
people of the goodness of what they do
and I'm always impatient about things so
I don't think it's improved as much as I
wanted to but there's certainly been a
lot of improvement certainly among the
young people in the industry I think the
next generation is going to be
completely different and everybody who
sees this approach the moral approach
just about everybody who's young and in
the industry they get really excited
about it so I have this you know sort of
one indication as I am somewhat of a
like a celebrity within that industry
which is not exciting in and of itself
but which is exciting in that a
philosopher and philosophy is is
commanding this because it's it's so
important and they're they're starting
to see it you know one other thing and I
haven't ridden out of my notes was on
page 205 again you publish the book in
2014 and you I pathi size that you know
we're going to see Pro fossil fuel
politicians winning over anti fossil
fuel politicians and I'm not going to
say you are responsible for the Trump
victory I'm not sure it's a good thing
but certainly that's what happened this
time around Trump was unapologetically
if not necessarily in a very informed
way Pro fossil fuel Hillary with Clinton
was very anti
so fuel to bring it back to trump and to
kind of wrap things up what are your
concerns about a trump presidency in a
trump energy policy because you know
even as I was thinking as you were
talking about you know if we went back
and talked to people living in London in
1800 and live in the bustle of the
Industrial Revolution and told them you
can't burn coal and they tell us to go
pound sand in many ways that's what the
developed world is trying to do to China
which is going through an industrial
revolution of its own and a
transformation and has by Western
standards terrible air air quality and a
lot of people in the West wanna say to
China and less developed countries you
know what you you don't have access to
fossil fuels because we burned them all
up and you're going to screw up the
planet Trump is a nationalist sees an
economic nationalist and a half of you
know a lot of what he ran on was China
bashing or trying to screw over China
trying to squeeze China down
economically you know does that kind of
does the economic nationalism of Trump
bother you in terms of energy policy or
are there other concerns where you think
he might get things spectacularly wrong
I have a different view of any
politician before they're elected versus
after they're elected in good physical
that's a smart smart way of thinking
about it for sure in terms of in terms
of what I as an individual can do what
any individual can do but I have I'm in
a position I believe to help things and
in energy you know energy is the issue
where I'll just say what about Trump I
think this is the issue that he is best
on so if we were talking about other
issues primarily say trade or you know
other things it would not be a position
maybe where I thought that I can be
helpful or or at least being helpful
would mean opposing the things that I
disagreed with about trade so I think
that once somebody is elected the
question is really what is their
positive that we can maximize and what
is their negative that we really need to
oppose and I see a lot of people
free-market people still kind of
the was it right to vote for Trump or
Hillary which methodologically that's an
interesting kind of thing but the fact
is that we've got a lot of important
issues on the table and that the outcome
of those issues is incredibly up in the
air much more up in the air than it
would have been under Hillary Hillary
you know I believe it I'm not saying I
supported her or supporter Trump I don't
say so publicly but Hillary would have I
think made every area of the economy
worse as signed sealed and delivered
like that was just aren t you know
Donald Trump in terms of what's going to
happen there's a lot that's up in the
air so my focus on energy has been what
can I do to maximize the chance of
something good happening and that's
that's the main thing I think I can do
because I think is pretty good policy
advisors is I'm really interested in the
issue of how they explain it to the
public I think you mentioned the issue
of like do his ideas make sense well I'm
concerned about are the arguments made
to the public going to make sense
because we could have the same policy
conclusion say about increasing fossil
fuel development but if you don't talk
about the issue of co2 if you don't talk
about the issue of emissions and how
that fits into your case then you're
going to alienate a lot of people and
you'll have what's happened in the past
whereas they'll just quote this one
tweet where he called global warming you
know in a Chinese Oaks right yeah those
by China
he's also said much more intelligent
things about that including that we have
to look at what's the magnitude of it
and how does it how significant is it in
the full context of the other things we
have to deal with which is exactly the
right general schematic way to think
about it but I've openly offered to help
any politician and so that include Trump
with if they're interested in in
pro-freedom policies which includes but
is not limited to Pro fossil fuel
policies if they're interested in
helping sell that and help persuade
people by giving people an argument
that's based on human flourishing that's
based on careful
thinking about the full context you know
I I want to help them so I'm hoping that
I can do that I certainly do not want
any kind of position within a government
or anything like that but you know I'm
openly eager to to help with that so
that that's my particular focus with
Trump everything else that I can do or
say I think is tiny in comparison to
what I could potentially do there I know
I would love I would get behind any
politician who actually talked in terms
of human flourishing and then had
policies that were even tangentially
related to human flourishing so we will
leave it there we have been talking with
Alex Epstein he is the president of the
Center for industrial progress we've
been talking about Trump's energy policy
as candidate and what might happen as
president Alex also wrote the really
powerful book from 2014 the moral case
for fossil fuels I highly recommend
reading it Alex thanks so much for
talking to us hey thanks so much Nick
this has been the reason podcast please
subscribe to us at iTunes and rate and
review us check us out at reason.com as
well where we have all of our written
articles as well as videos and other
treats for the mind and the imagination
for reason I'm Nick Gillespie